they're calling this year the year of
revenge travel when people will finally
get back to taking those trips that they
had planned and put off and now they're
making up for lost time so travel expert
melissa gonzalo is joining us from
puerto vallarta with some tips and some
inspiration and i have to say some fomo
because i just wish that you know i
could be doing this segment in person
look at that
yes i wish you could be here with me
enjoying this beautiful breeze as you
can see i got the beyonce thing going oh
my gosh okay so tell us about puerto
vallarta and about your trip really
quick
yes i'm coming to you uh from the
presidential suite here at the maria
puerto vallarta resort and spa with this
gorgeous balcony view of banteras bay
behind me absolutely stunning here this
is a quintessential resort experience
for anyone wanting to come back south of
the border want to travel
internationally again this has got to be
your first stop they have the biggest
infinity pool in all of puerto vallarta
they even have their own brand of
tequila because this is jalisco after
all the land of tequila and they have a
tequila sommelier on site so you can
learn a sip like a pro and they have an
amazing deal going on right now for
families called discover puerto vallarta
and two kids and two two kids two adults
get free breakfast every day and they
get twenty percent off food and beverage
and the kids can eat stay and play at
the kids club for free while the parents
go enjoy the new ceviche and tequila bar
and have some tequila tasting so there's
something for everyone here oh my god i
love that and of course you know you
need your documents to travel the world
um are there any places that you can go
without a passport though for people at
home who might not have one right now or
might not have those renewed you don't
have your passport renewed because i
know a lot of people are like i want to
travel internationally again but i don't
have my passport right so if you still
want the tropical flare with the latin
style you can go to puerto rico from
puerto vallarta to puerto rico don't
need your passport to go there and the
caribbean hilton is an amazing choice
there's an iconic hotel just minutes
from old san juan and it's been there
for years it's newly remodeled i've
actually stayed there twice it's
absolutely gorgeous it has a private
beach and of course stuff for the kids
as well if the parents want to go and
enjoy some dining options there's 11
different dining options on site and
biggest plus here it's the original home
of the pina colada invented there by
bartender in 1954. the florida keys is
always a great option absolutely
beautiful gorgeous sunsets
super relaxing and it's just an hour
drive from miami or fort lauderdale
airport but the playa largo resort and
spa is absolutely beautiful it's on 14
acres of beachfront property absolutely
stunning they have hammocks all over the
property they have private bonfires and
they just debut their ocean residences
so you can take groups of families or
groups of friends maybe you're
celebrating a wedding but you can still
enjoy the resort amenities you just have
these private homes there which is
absolutely amazing and they have really
cool eco tours and nature walks they
have a cool sunset one called the
twilight eco tour it ends with pineapple
cocktails water table side uh dining
an experience that's really unique and
of course gorgeous sunsets there that
you can't beat wow okay the fomo is real
over here in las vegas i'm ready to take
a trip to a tropical land and i love
that you have ideas for to get the
tropical vibes but you don't need your
passport so that's a great advice thank
you enjoy your trip thank you